بعدما كان هذا المبنى شاهدا على قصه نجاح
تويتر الان هو مسرح هنا لنزيف من الموظفين
المستقيلين من الشركه استقالات واقالات
لاكثر من نصف موظفي تويتر تهدد مصيره واحد
من ابرز مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
الموظفون لم يسمح لهم بدخول المبنى مؤقتا
وحتى يوم الاثنين بامر من مسك نفسه رغم
انه طلب الاجتماع بمن يجيد البرمجه يوم
الجمعه فخوره الموضوع تكمله في ان
المغادرين جزء منهم مهندسون وتقنيون
يعملون بالاساس على ابقاء تويتر يعمل
بانسيابيه وغيابهم يعني ازدياد احتماليه
حدوث مشاكل كبيره
وفيما يرى بعضه ان استحواذ ايلول الماسك
على تويتر لتعديل السياسات المتعلقه
بالمحتوى يهدد الموقع يروج اخرون لرؤيته
خاصه المتعلقه ببناءه الاثنين الحسين
الطاوضه العربيه سان فران سكو